mam takie wrażenie
że chyba nie zdaję sobie pan premier Morawiecki sprawy
ile rozliczeń jego czeka
i ile razy będzie stawał przed komisjami śledzczymi
przed prokuraturą
będzie się tłumaczył z decyzji
swojego rządu i swoich ludzi
myślę że jeżeli przyjdą prawdziwe rozliczenia
to Tam gdzie były prawdziwe przekręty
a prawdziwe przekręty odkrywamy i będziemy odkrywali
decyzja komisji
że 1 z pierwszych 1.
EE przesłuchanym przez komisją będzie Jarosław gowin
to dobra decyzja
bo wyświetli i pokażę na początku
gdzie byliśmy w tamtym czasie
a to był czas
który pod kurtyną niewiedzy pis chciałby schować